Huge mess. Diversity basically
is when you have a diverse pool of people.
And diversity is not only obvious,
diversity is not only gender,
for example,
if you're female,
male or neutral,
not only your sexual orientation,
not only the color of your skin.
It's not only, you know,
the obvious stuff that we talk
when we're talking about diversity.
Diversity is also your diversity of thoughts,
your diversity of mind,
your diversity of background.
Your age is a diversity if you who had,
was raised in like a traditional home,
if you're raised by a diplomat traveling the world
where you studied is your diversity.
If you only have diversity of thoughts
and you don't have the other part,
which is inclusion, belonging.